je vais manger boire et banderoles
demandant et en public
il n'y a aucune loi dans la législation
tunisienne qui qui dit que tout le monde
doit jeûner ou que les non jeûneurs ne
peuvent pas le faire en public justement
fatale en tunisie à me dire non jeûneurs
ça reste un tabou
ça reste quelque chose que les gens vous
font discrètement ce qui est je dirais
que ce qu'il affirme
et le revendique et sont une minorité
mais pas ceux qui le font
il
moi je me sens déjà très bien parce que
le mouvement et l'herbe est
majoritairement très très jeunes ils
sont lycéens s'est réduit ce que j'ai
fait toute ma vie c'est de nous cacher
aller chercher un petit café paroisse
pas cher et boire manger un truc et
c'est tout à mes yeux elle veut plus je
vais manger boire et banderoles
demandant et en public
nous avons marre de toute cette
hypocrisie
les awards pour chasser